one more thing on the Reuben report here
we go what I thought was cool about
bringing you two together is that even
though you guys are in different fields
of work being women in your respective
fields is a little outside the norm for
comedy and for news and I thought I
could get you both to share a little bit
about what it's like to be a woman in
comedy and a news I just sort of said
that on top of itself oh yeah all right
I'll start I used to be a magician's
assistant you know woman in news well
it's interesting because Barbara Walters
is retiring yeah and she was the first
female anchor so it kind of gives you a
sense of how new it is for a woman to be
in the media um and you know as a woman
in the media you realize that there are
certain advantages that men have over
you but women have certain advantages
over men and so I don't know if it
really balances or balances out but
there there are definitely some
challenges but you just push through and
you you become a trailblazer and you
make it easier for younger generations
there are younger generations to succeed
you know you make it a little easier for
them you're so easy though yeah I'm
gonna follow up with that my first
comedy a TSA when you when you started
in the comedy scene young ears and the
Kevin DS the late 70s putting the buoy
this is my 40th year whoa and this turns
out to be a webcast I I told your
manager at NBC but whatever the point is
so but we the boom of the 80s yeah and
all this stuff was happening for four
convicts neither the exam but it seemed
like it happened more for guys so you
know that my theory first of all I love
what you said and and I love that you're
gorgeous and serious and brilliant
because people always separate it you
know when I was starting in the 70s they
say oh you're good looking for a female
no no that's you know it's such an awful
thing but my my take on all of it has
always been you have to be the best
anything you can be in you ignore all
the chatter and just go out and do your
job I you know I really think whoever
can carry you
out of the burning building gets to be
the fireman and if you're catching fire
on the 10th floor and a woman comes up
and she can throw you over her shoulder
you're not going to say oh no you know
what's a woman fireman she's saving your
life whereas if a man came and couldn't
lift you go cheek he's not going to save
my life but at least it's a guy firing
you have 10 seconds to be funny on stage
after that that's it they forget what
you are there laughing and you know no
one ever said oh man she's so funny too
bad it's a woman or OG he's not funny
but at least it's a guys do your job
really well and no one can say a word
yeah so my last question on this is how
much you think that looks play into the
respective fields because if you look at
if you will yes certainly every field
but especially you know you both are
public figures and if you were to turn
on fox news right now every the men look
like garbage basically and the women all
have to look perfect on yahoo a higher
standard and yeah when it comes to looks
and i hate when people deny that i hate
when i make that statement on the show
and guys like no guys are totally judged
by the way through that's true to some
degree right but definitely not the same
standard web base into them right you
will see gray haired newscasters with
their beautiful lines and all their life
experience and every woman is like a
potato you know it's it's just not that
you know that it has to change and but I
started talk I had a talk with my family
on Mother's Day and I was like I gotta
come up with a good business idea
something that's sustainable that'll
like it'll be my great plan B and my
moms like plan B for what I was like oh
there's not a lot of longevity in my
career like you know at 40 I'm gonna
freak the hell out because no one's
gonna want to hire me and I know that
that sounds really harsh but it's the
reality is because some hot toddy it
like 25 is gonna come in and I know that
I'm in that group right now all right
but she's gonna come in and some TV exec
is gonna be what you're also qualified
which makes it good I have you watched
cable news though yes but not qualified
I know but Diane Sawyer is not allowed
to look like Andy Rooney you understand
the choices Diane Sawyer has been pulled
I mean I love her and she's great but
she has to do what she has to do in
order to keep her career Andy Rooney
looked like an unmade bed yeah it was
okay because he was a man can you
imagine if a woman would have ever come
on
eyebrows flying everywhere they never
gold to me or had an uneven run again
because your eyebrows you know it just
doesn't they don't let you in and
studies have shown that good looking
people are given more leeway more
quarter more respect so it's just look
it's a cosmetic world now it used to be
a cosmetic business now it's a cosmetic
world and you do suffer I gained weight
i'm having trouble i'm waiting for
someone to pay me to lose it but if they
don't i'll just have to lose it but how
did he know something there has been
some sort of seismic shift because there
was a feeling at one time that for all
kamiya for men and women that if you
were this sort of slovenly loser that
that was funny and now if you look at
all the women that are hot right now in
comedy it's Whitney Cummings and Sarah
Silverman and but you know what you can
also go the other way in a lot of
instances it's looks and no they're not
funny and it's really horrible um but
when you look at Lenny Bruce was
stunning man and Richard Pryor was a
gorgeous man and Eddie Murphy is a
gorgeous man having both will get you
further he just has rushes on comedians
oh not it run run for your life yeah no
I just think in every instance looks
will get you further and you know it's
and sometimes it gets you more than you
then your talent will support and look
at the weather my husband runs in every
night for the weather because we call
them the weather strippers oh yeah my
goodness whether that's from just moving
here for a couple of months your weather
people in this town what is going on
there meteorology no one is in school
for to be a meteorologist anymore
they're just getting implants and
learning how to point yeah that's it so
the point is if you're not very skilled
but you're willing to do some cosmetic
work become a weather person but if you
are skilled and you're pretty you can
become a comedian or a news anchor and
i'm dave rubin that's been the rubin
report i will see you next week
pinellas is the official outfitter of
the Ruben report I want to put you in
this shirt go to bonobos com enter code
trr 20 for twenty percent off your first
purchase